So my name's Dustin Tingley.
I'm a professor of government
and the new faculty director
of HILT. And I'm just so pleased
that everyone has come out
and is having a great time.
So before we get
started, I just wanted
to remind folks
that if you wanted
to enter in some
questions into the poll,
you can look over
here for the website.
That would be great.
As a little added
incentive, if we
choose one of your
questions, Alan
has agreed to put his voice
on your home voicemail.
He actually hasn't, but
I thought it would work.
Sorry, boss.
So before we get started
with this last session,
I just want to take a second
to really thank the HILT team--
Cassie McGrath, Allison Pingree,
Jaime Goldstein, Zach Wang,
and Melissa Godet.
They've just done such an
amazing job in organizing this.
The amount of thought and
detail that goes into this
is just amazing.
You know, briefers for all the
people involved, et cetera.
And super honored
that some friends
of Sarah Shaughnessy and
Brooke Pulitzer and others
have come to chip in, as well.
So we just really,
really appreciate that.
Furthermore, I just want
to take another second
to honor Erin Driver-Linn.
I know she was
honored this morning,
but I'm going to
get my piece, too.
So as many of you know, Erin was
the founding director of HILT
and led HILT for I'm
going to say eight years.
Because it wasn't
really just starting
with the first conference.
It was more than that, right?
There was a lot
of lead up to that
that Erin really invested in.
And I think personally-- but
I suspect I speak for a lot
of folks--
Erin has not just been a friend,
but a real mentor and teacher,
right?
In some senses, I feel
like I've gone through what
I'm going to call--
I'm going to create
a new department
called EDL, Erin Driver-Linn.
So I feel like I've gone through
EDL 101, 102, 103, 104, 105,
106.
Like, I'm going to
get another degree.
I always wanted another degree.
And I just-- it's amazing.
I looked into a
little bit of data.
You haven't been able to teach
any classes in your capacity.
But in some senses, you've been
running one of the most highly
subscribed informal
learning experiences
in the history of
Harvard University.
And that is just tremendous.
And I feel like we owe
the whole HILT team
and Erin a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
So now, to switch
gears a little bit,
we're really honored to have
today both Provost Alan Garber
and the incoming Vice Provost
for Advances in Learning Bharat
Anand.
Both of them have had huge
impacts throughout Harvard
already, and we thought
it would be a great idea
to get these folks
together and let them have
a conversation with each other.
And I thought I would
just kind of kick it off
by asking both to kind of
reflect in the past seven
years, what's some of
the things that we've
learned about teaching
and learning at Harvard
in the last seven years.
And we'll take it from there.
Bharat, you should
take advantage of this.
This may be the
last time that we're
allowed to publicly disagree.
And you should start out.
Looking at sort of the landscape
more broadly beyond what
we do here, which
I think many of us
have been doing for
the last several years,
I had three observations.
The first is, as
much as we would
like to believe that the
challenges we are confronting
are entirely different
from what anyone
else in the history of
organizations has confronted,
I think this is--
I think we're sort of seeing the
early stages of how many what
I would call content
industries have played out
for the last quarter century.
And so what do I mean by that?
One of the things that some of
you know I have written about
is that when digital
came along, we've
almost gone through three phases
in many of these other markets
or businesses, whether we
think about, by the way,
music or newspapers or
media more generally.
The first is what we might
call the phase of optimizing
on reach, which is, you
know, the big attractiveness
of digital technologies
was we don't
need to distribute a
newspaper to 100 people.
We can reach a million people.
The same thing goes
for education, right?
And so reach you might
think of as phase one.
And that's, by the way, a
big attraction of digital.
But the moment you
start thinking about it,
there's at least two
other benefits we get,
which we might
call interactivity,
which is we're not just reaching
people through information
transfer, but unlike,
let's say, radio and TV
and so on, people
can talk back to us.
And that has many benefits.
So let's call that sort
of benefit of type two.
And benefit of
type three is when
we realize it's not just
what we might call hub
to spoke transfers or
spoke to hub communication,
but spoke to spoke.
And I've called
that connectedness.
What's interesting is
all the digital giants
we talk about are phase
three kind of firms.
That's just a lens
through which at least I
look at what's happening.
And what's interesting
to me is much
of what we're seeing
in the edtech space
or even education more
broadly is literally
examples of these three
kinds of organizations.
Peer learning is an example
of phase three, which,
you know, I think has huge
implications going forward,
which we're just
beginning to scratch.
In different parts
of the university,
we've started seeing
the benefits of this.
But the other thing I just want
to throw out is that, you know,
I've spent a lot of time looking
at newspaper organizations,
and one of the things
that's interesting
is the people who
actually survived
the digital transition
are not necessarily
the folks in those organizations
who are the most tech savvy.
They were the folks who believed
in the art of storytelling.
And that's actually
something useful to keep
in mind, which is that
technology is just
an instrument.
I mean, it's here for us.
It's up to us to figure out how
to use this most powerfully.
And the example I just
want to use-- and then,
maybe this intersects with even
the topic of the conference
about the science of learning--
is a story that David Garvin,
who was one of my
colleagues at HBS,
probably one of the most
thoughtful people on campus
when it came to thinking
about teaching and learning--
and I know many of
you interact with him.
When I came to the university as
a faculty member 21 years ago,
David was amongst a group of
faculty who were teaching us
about teaching.
And I still remember one story
he told us, which some of you
may have heard.
He said, you know, when you
think about closing a class,
here's one way to close a class.
Let's say you're telling
a story about a kingdom
and what happened to
the king and queen,
and the queen died, and
then, the king died.
You know, that's one
way to close the story.
Here's another way to close
that same story, which
is to say the queen
died, and then, the king
died of a broken heart.
And what is fascinating was
now that I think back to that,
we didn't need to measure
which one was most effective.
You know, that was--
you knew immediately.
And this is just something that
I have found really powerful
and goes back to, in fact, some
of the comments in the morning
session that Erin
was mentioning,
which is when we think about
the science of learning,
there's a lot of things
that we can actually
do pretty well on in terms
of quantitative information
and measurement.
But there's also a lot
of things which we just
know in the classroom are
working and not working.
I was speaking with
Gary King recently,
and Gary and his
usual incredible way
just gave me some advice.
He said everything about
improving teaching and learning
is a measurement problem.
And I was like, OK, I've
got to start taking notes.
And he said, ultimately,
you want feedback.
And you want feedback
more frequently than just
once in the semester.
You might want it
twice in the semester.
once every class.
You might want it
during the class.
And you start thinking
about the idea,
and wow, this is
actually pretty profound.
But then, my reaction was,
hold on a second, Gary.
When we actually do or
engage in active learning,
I don't need any observed
or measurable feedback.
I can see it in the students.
I can see it
throughout the class.
And he was like,
wow, that's actually
a great point,
which is, you know,
I need feedback
when I'm lecturing.
And so again, you know,
what's interesting to me
is these things are
often compliments,
but it speaks to this
core question, which
is when we think about
the trends of digital
and how it impacts
teaching and learning,
it's useful actually to think in
these three terms-- at least I
found it useful-- which
is reach, interactively,
and connectedness.
I'll just say a couple
of other things.
A direct implication of
that-- and I think most
of the organizations or
innovations that I've seen over
the last six to seven years
which have really impacted
my thinking are ones which have
put the learner at the center
of the enterprise--
pedagogy and learning at the
center of the enterprise-- as
opposed to the content.
That's not a trivial
observation, I don't think.
And it has some pretty
important implications.
And what does that mean in
terms of how we actually
set up an organization that's
designed to improve things?
What does it mean in terms
of even something as simple
as saying, well, if you're
going to improve that, this
is a corollary, perhaps?
Content and technology
ought to sit side by side.
Because any ideas we get about
improving content or learning
or pedagogy must ultimately
be reflected in the platforms.
You know, again,
I'm not thinking
about what that means in
terms of implications for us
as a university, but
it's just an observation.
So that's the other thing that
I would say is, I believe,
absolutely essential.
And the third is--
and this is an obvious
statement coming from me--
that strategy matters.
And what do I mean by that?
I keep saying that
when we were starting
in our small world, HBX,
about five or six years ago,
the most useful three months
we spent during the last five
years were the first three
months when all we were doing
was just asking, "Who
are we tried to target?
What's the problem
we're trying to solve?
And what can we do as an
institution that differentiates
ourselves from everyone else?"
Because once you're
in the online space,
anyone can offer anything.
What gives us a license to play?
And in some sense,
those questions
have been incredibly powerful.
When I look across the landscape
of organizations, again,
I see it's not surprising that
we should ask those questions,
it is surprising how many don't.
So that's the other--
that's the other thing
I'd just throw out.
Well, I hope you can all see why
Bharat was the obvious choice
to become the next vice provost
for advances in learning.
Nobody has thought
more thoroughly
about these issues, particularly
the issues of strategy,
when it comes to learning, and
especially online learning.
And to those of you
who haven't read it,
I'd like to highly recommend his
book, The Content Trap, where
he really developed
some of the ideas
that he just touched
upon lightly here.
But it'll give you
a really good idea
about digital
technologies in general,
but particularly about learning.
I want to say a little bit about
the question Dustin posed--
what's the most
important thing we've
learned about teaching
and learning at Harvard
in the last seven years?
And I can't pretend to
speak for anybody but me
in answering that question.
Seven years, by the
way, corresponds
to how long I've
been here as provost,
so it's kind of easy for me
to think about the beginning
and today.
And, by the way, my answer
when people ask what
surprised you most when
you came to Harvard--
and many of you have heard me
say this at previous health
conferences.
The biggest surprise to
me was how many people
cared so deeply about teaching.
That was not, in my view, what
Harvard's outside reputation
was.
And I won't say that every
person who teaches at Harvard
has a real passion
for it, but I would
say an amazing fraction
of people who teach here
care deeply about the teaching.
And in fact, even some people
who don't put as much effort
into it as we might like, it's a
matter of competing priorities.
It's not that they disparage
teaching in any way
or don't place a
high value in it.
And, you know, it's
a tough thing to say.
But I think most people really
do care here about teaching.
But anyway, that was
an initial impression
based on my first
couple of years here.
Now, I would say it has much
more to do with the challenges
in disseminating, in gaining
adoption of innovations,
and teaching on our campus.
And I don't think it's
unique to Harvard.
I think many of you are
familiar with the history of how
we created edX and
HarvardX, and I just
want to remind you that
we had three goals.
One was to make
courses at Harvard
and other top institutions
available to everybody
with an internet connection.
That's kind of the externally
facing goal that we had.
The second was to
conduct research
into how people learn,
taking advantage
of this digital platform.
And then, the third, which
actually in my role as provost
is the one that I would
put the most emphasis on,
was to improve teaching
on our own campuses.
In other words, to use our
investments in online learning
to improve face to face
teaching, the kind that
occurs on our campuses.
And so for me, maybe
the biggest findings--
and you could say that's just a
nice way of saying frustration
with lack of progress--
has been in how these
technologies have had impact
or not had impact
on our campuses.
And here, I really want to
focus on Harvard, of course.
And, you know, you
think about the problem
that we set for ourselves is
we think we're experimenting,
coming up with new and
better methods for teaching.
Why don't people adopt them,
these better new methods?
And I remember when we
started with edX and HarvardX,
the people who had worked
on teaching effectiveness
and how people
learn had a number
of very important findings
that could easily be applied,
and this entire
literature was largely
ignored by the pioneers
in developing MOOCs
and other forms of
online learning.
So you start out with the
fact that there actually
was a good evidence base
that was, to a great extent,
ignored.
Well, we'll set that aside, but
it's part of the same issue.
And I would contend that
part of what we've learned
is that if you care
about teaching,
you also have strong
opinions about how to teach.
And to get people to
adopt different methods
is not that easy.
And I can't blame anybody
who teaches a course
for demanding a high
standard of evidence
before changing what they do.
And in fact, when it
comes to online learning,
we have a number of
really, I believe,
interesting and important
research results,
but I don't think we're yet
at the point-- and Dustin,
you should feel
free to disagree.
But I don't think we're at
the point where we can say,
we absolutely know the best way
to organize an online course
so that people will learn.
And I'm very much in the Gary
King camp about the importance
and measurement and
so on, but I want
to point out that the greatest
barrier to measurement
is not so much obtaining the
measure, although, I have
to say that turned out to be
far harder than I imagined
at the beginning.
That required changing
platform, making
all kinds of adjustments that
took time and a lot of effort.
The biggest issue
is agreeing on what
is your measure of success.
What are the
outcomes to measure?
And I was struck by what
you said about you could
see in the students' faces.
Well, that is one
kind of outcome.
But what if you're interested--
what if you're interested
in how much people
can apply the results
of their learning
a year after they have
completed a course?
You don't get immediate
feedback on that by definition.
It's not obvious
how to measure it.
And the studies
that have been done
are discouraging,
so I don't think
there's a lot of
enthusiasm for doing it.
But, in fact, that's
a huge issue, right?
If we're going to
conduct research,
we have to decide what
outcomes really matter.
And that's a very important
substantive question.
So people require-- they
need to be convinced
if they're going to change
how they teach, especially
if, by their own beliefs,
they've been pretty
successful at how they teach.
But I would add a
big part of this
is that the people
who care care deeply.
And that doesn't only
lead to skepticism.
It means that there are
coordination problems.
You know, you might agree
with other approaches,
what other people
are doing if you
didn't have that much at stake.
In here, I have to
say, if you just
take a look at the last
few years at Harvard,
we've had major
teaching initiatives
in multiple schools.
To name a few, the
school of public health
developed a mostly
online master's
of public health program.
The law school is
currently engaged
in a review of its
curriculum and anticipating
curriculum reform.
And by the way, I
haven't seen a case
where a school engages
in curricular reform
without thinking
about how they teach.
It's not just about
what the content is.
The medical school
instituted yet
another new pathway
program, which
is really a major change
in how they teach.
The ed school is reorganizing
its master's programs
after really extensive
community conversations.
And within FAS, the reform
of the gen ed program,
the new gen ed, which I
think was probably at least,
what, a three year effort,
a very prolonged effort--
so there has been
a lot going on.
And in every case, it's been
difficult. It's been difficult.
And it has not been
difficult because of apathy.
It's been difficult
because people care.
So when we think about how we
apply what we're learning, how
we adopt innovations,
we have to also think
about what is the milieu.
What's the environment?
What are the norms
within the schools?
How much authority do
faculty have over the courses
they teach?
And here, I have to
say, the business school
is really different from many
other parts of the university.
You can think of the
business school and FAS
as being on somewhat different
ends of the spectrum.
Well, in the business
school, some of the courses
are essentially
institutional, right?
The content may be changed a
little bit from year to year,
but it's about the course
rather than the faculty member
teaching it for some of
the core courses, where
in FAS, very often, it's
the faculty's creation.
So as you can imagine,
to roll out innovations
and how that's taught requires
convincing and individual
faculty members.
So that's what I think
is most important now.
And I care about this
hugely because really, we
are at our core a residential
teaching institution.
And if we're going to be
a successful university,
we have to continue to improve
our teaching and learning.
Thank you.
It's interesting that in the
course of both of your comments
on the past seven years, how
much you wove in your thoughts
about the future and
what you're excited about
and what you feel good about.
Maybe we could just, inspired
by President Bacow's comments
this morning, kind of
pivot into situating
Harvard's efforts a little bit
more broadly within society.
What excites you
about what we're
doing that will have an impact
beyond our own learners,
of course, or even our own
learners in online courses,
but even more generally?
How is Harvard going to be a
leader in the field of teaching
and learning for
society more generally?
Or excuse me.
Not necessarily a leader,
but also a partner.
I think that was a big part
of President Bacow's comments.
What are ways that we're
thinking about partnering?
What are the issues
that we're trying
to solve in a more
general societal level?
Well, this is a great
question, Dustin.
And I'd really like
to be able to draw
on the wisdom in
the room about that,
but I can say a little bit about
how we're thinking about some
of the issues.
We believe-- and here, I think
I speak for the leadership
of the university, and that
includes many of the deans--
that we have an obligation
to society within the US
as well as overseas,
and we're very concerned
about the future of work.
We're not the only ones
concerned about that,
obviously.
But you think about people who
will lose their jobs because
of automation.
And economists have a course
of debate about what happens
with technological change.
Will there be new
jobs to replace
the ones that disappear?
And I'm generally in the camp
that answers that question yes.
But for individuals,
there are individuals
who will lose their jobs.
Unless they acquire an entirely
different new set of skills,
they're not really
going to be employable.
And we feel that we need to
have something to offer there.
We thought a lot about
using edX and maybe
HarvardX to help
with reskilling,
but frankly, you think about
what our strengths are.
We're not going to replace
what a community college does.
That's not our
comparative advantage.
But one thing that
we do very well
is teach leaders
and teach teachers.
And I think many of you
know this is Dustin's work.
I believe that a huge fraction
of people who learn on HarvardX
are themselves teachers.
It can be secondary
school teachers, sometimes
college teachers.
And we really need
to think about how
we can up our game in
that regard and make sure
that we are contributing to the
solutions to these problems.
Now, the reason-- one of
the reasons I particularly
appreciate your wisdom
is we don't really
know how to do
that yet, but it's
a topic of very
active discussion,
and there are many people around
the university who care deeply
about this issue.
And Larry going out to
Pontiac and to Detroit
has made a very public statement
that we care deeply about what
happens in parts of
the country that people
think we've ignored.
The fact is we've never ignored
the heartland of the US,
but we have not trumpeted it
the way that we might have done.
And I don't know if
Larry mentioned this,
but when he went to Detroit
and Pontiac, basically
all of these leaders
he met with were alumni
of the college, of the ed
school, of the Kennedy School,
and so on.
So we have a presence,
and we have an obligation
to contribute.
Did you want to add
anything to that?
So maybe I'll come back to the
first part of your question,
which is actually thinking
about opportunities
going forward as I
see it within Harvard,
just to make that more
explicit, and then
thinking beyond Harvard.
So I have to say I'm excited
about what lies ahead of us.
And maybe this is because
there's still 10 days before I
assume the new role.
And, of course, you're
spending zero time on it now.
Yeah.
It's coming.
But if I think about
the opportunities,
at least I'm sort of
mentally classifying them
into three or four.
The first one has
to do with something
that came up this morning about
how do we even think about what
or when student
interactions occur with us.
I think historically, we've
obviously thought about it
when students come to campus.
It's a very different
way of looking
at how interactions
occur with us today, now
that we have digital learning.
One of things that
several schools have now
seen over the last few years--
HBS.
HMS.
The Kennedy School is moving
in this direction of the law
school.
Perhaps even FAS-- is
start to think about
what can we do to help students
before they come to campus.
By the way, that's a
non-trivial task and impact.
20% of our students don't know
the basic language of business
before they step foot
on the HBS campus.
That was where we
focused our efforts.
If we think about
prematriculations--
so this is now students' time
before they come to campus--
let's just, for the
sake of symmetry,
extend it to the other
end of the spectrum, which
is what happens in the 50 years
after they leave us on campus.
And lifelong
learning is something
we've always aspired to
try and crack the code of.
I think it's fair to say we have
not been as successful as we
would like.
But now that we start
looking at the platforms
that we have built
around the university--
and these are not just
asynchronous platforms,
but synchronous
digital platforms
where we are, in fact,
engaging with alums
in some interesting ways--
the potential there, I think,
is massive, absolutely massive.
So that's sort of one
aspect, which is just looking
at time of these interactions.
The second is-- and this is
picking up something that Alan
referred to--
there's been a
lot of innovation,
actually, across the different
schools in different areas.
So for instance, the HarvardX
content creation team,
which I'm now sort of
beginning to just appreciate--
the talent in that team
is pretty incredible.
If we think about
the other parts
of what makes online
learning effective,
it's digital marketing.
Well, we've started to build
out centers of excellence
in areas like DC
and other schools.
If we think about
platforms, some of us
have actually built those.
I think there could be
massive complimentarities
in actually starting to not
just share information and best
practices, but sharing
assets, fixed investments,
across the university.
I mean, this is where one
plus one could equal three.
The third is complementarities
between residential and online
and research and online.
And both of these are sort
of typically considered
as the toughest nuts to crack.
Let me just say why I'm
optimistic, actually,
which is--
I mean, take research
for a second.
I think research has sort of
become cool in the last decade.
And, you know, I don't know
if we call this the TED
effect or the Gladwell
effect, or call it
whatever you want to call it.
But people with
ideas have audiences.
If we start thinking about what
we can offer to our faculty--
and this goes back to the
core strength of Harvard--
if we can offer
digital platforms that
actually allow them to
disseminate ideas, not just
courses, wow.
There's a lot of
possibilities there.
And this is one of the places
I'm beginning to think about,
which is short form content,
not just 30 hour courses.
I mean, one of the things
that some of you heard me say
is if we took pen to paper
and just asked the question,
"What's should
Harvard do online?"
it would be a
complete coincidence
if the answer was 50
hour long courses, right?
That's just a mirror of
what we do residentially.
There's so much more
we can do online.
And the same for residential.
I mean, now that we have digital
first platforms, you know,
there are many ways to
integrate them with residential.
I was talking with
Alyssa yesterday.
Gen ed is going to
kick off next year.
What if we actually just
took three or four courses
and we're very deliberate right
at the outset about saying,
can we carve out what the
blended version of this
might look like for
our on campus students?
So in a sense, I see
complementarities
across schools, over
time for learners,
between different activities.
That's what I see.
But the key point that
I'm trying to make
is that oftentimes, we
can enable innovation
and improvements
by enabling others
who are operating at
so-called the last mile, which
is all the teachers.
Sometimes, we can
actually engage in them
through deliberate
efforts to innovate.
And I wouldn't understate
the importance of that.
So that's why I'm
personally excited.
You know, everything that
Alan has been talking about,
Larry's been talking
about in terms of you
now start looking
beyond Harvard.
What can we do with
the school system?
Not just higher education,
but K through 12.
What can we do with
job retraining?
I mean, this
potential is massive.
And at least mentally,
the model that I have
is not one where we go out
and create the solution.
I think Larry used
the word humble.
We ought to be a little
humble in thinking
about what we can do.
But really thinking
of a wholesale model
where if we have done
something which deserves
or merits sharing
with the world, let's
partner with those who
are feet on the ground.
You know, we have examples
already of this on campus.
David Moss, who's
one of my colleagues,
was teaching a course to the
undergraduates on democracy.
Some of the undergrads
went to him afterwards
and said, "You know what?
We'd love to share your
case-based materials
with our high school
teachers in civics."
To cut the long story
short, David now
has a two-day residential
seminar with 150 high school
teachers every year.
This is a multiplier effect.
It's not trying to
say, let's go directly
to the learner with
these case materials,
but let's partner with
those who, in fact, do
this in the last mile.
The same thing
with the ed school.
I mean, the courses
that have been created,
one just got put out,
which was targeting
principals of schools.
It's an online course.
By the way, kudos to
everyone on that project.
This is just spectacular by
any stretch of the imagination.
I was speaking to
someone last month
who runs an organization
which coaches principals.
Like, these are
people on the ground
in the schools who help them
on administrative skills,
teaching, and so
on and so forth.
And she was saying, "We don't
have any digital materials."
And I said, you
know, "Guess what?
Our ed school just
created some."
Connected them.
And there's massive
complementarities there,
as well.
So, you know, start thinking
about the possibilities.
And, you know, I'd say that when
we approach these much bigger
problems, at least
the way I'd love
for us to think about it is just
to be very clear about where we
want to play, how
we can play in a way
that amplifies, as opposed to
tries to do it on their own.
Great.
Thank you.
So we have a couple
more minutes.
I thought that it would be
nice to open it up to the crowd
and get a couple of
questions and some responses.
Who would like to ask
our panelists something?
Thank you.
So I'd like to raise the
ugly issue of monetization.
I come from a particular place.
I was an early adopter and big
fan of Eric Mazur's learning
catalytics, and I still
use it, but it eventually
got sold to Pearson,
and now, we kind of
have to go hat in hand
to the people at Pearson
and say, you know, "I
teach in this course.
I'm a Harvard professor.
Can I get 30 seats
for this class?"
And so that kind
of changes things.
And I'm just curious.
I heard-- you know, at one
of these breakout sessions,
I heard all of these
fantastic-- you know,
DART and all these great tools.
And right now, they all
look like they're free,
and the question is how long
are things going to be free,
and to what extent do they
have to become self-financing?
Dustin, you should
take that one.
[LAUGHTER]
So it's a great question.
I would note that I
believe historically
speaking, wasn't the learning--
that was funded by--
yeah, that's for HILT So
look, let me put it this way.
If you've got any problems with
Pearson, you just come to me
and I'll take care
of those bad boys.
The enforcer.
But it's a great question.
I mean, I have to say,
as someone who has helped
create some of
those tools, someone
who helped create DART with
Daniel Seaton and others
and working in
partnership with Hewitt,
this is something that we
are building for the Harvard
community in some-- so DART is
just a platform that lets you
search through digital
content like HarvardX content,
preview it, embed it
into your Canvas course.
dart.harvard.edu.
Go for it.
That was built, in
some ways, to leverage
a different investment that
was HarvardX, right, initially.
And so that was--
how can we do more with what
we've already invested in?
So there's already, you
know, just multiplying
that investment here.
But that is absolutely something
that, at least for the policy
matter, in my view,
would always be
available to Harvard faculty.
It's Harvard content anyways.
We want that content to be used.
There's brilliant
content out there.
content that people
like Alyssa Goodman and
others are developing that are
useful for our classes.
So that's something where
there's no question in my mind
that, you know, that's something
that for the Harvard community,
we want to be made available.
It's also something
where we want to make
some of that open more broadly.
But we have to be thinking about
sustainability, as well, right?
And if there are partner
institutions that,
for example, see value in
that technology in a way
that I see value
in that technology,
then they should chip in.
Let's make the
product better, right?
That's a different
form of monetization.
It's more of a
consortium type approach.
But those are all things
that I'm certainly open to.
And if you have a great idea
about a new ed technology
that you do want to
monetize, come to me
and we'll try to
figure something out,
as long as I get a piece.
Could I just add
something to that?
So what I actually appreciate
is that the debate today is
no longer what it was,
let's say, 10 years ago,
when at least sometimes,
the premise was everything
we offer online should be free.
Right now-- now, if you
actually start digging
into that premise,
there's a reason
that people who advocate that
are seeing it, which is let's
make education accessible to
those who can't afford it.
That's the premise.
It's not that we don't have cost
that we don't need to cover.
So I'm actually glad the debate
has actually moved beyond that.
As I actually think
about the possibilities,
frankly, I think there's many.
One of the reasons--
when we were thinking about
pricing five years ago--
this was the business
school courses--
a lot of people would
look at us and say,
"You guys must
have known exactly
how to do the conjoint
analysis to figure out
that the optimal
price was $1,500."
We had no clue, OK?
The debates were ranging
from $50 to $5,000.
Why $50?
Because we wanted to make
this accessible to people
who can't afford it.
Why did we end up where we did?
Because this costs
massive amounts
of money to get this right.
What was our answer?
The answer was $1,500, but $100
for those who can't afford it.
And so financially,
it becomes, even
in the online market, a nice
way to price discriminate.
You start taking that a
little further, I mean,
there's a lot of
variation in the demand
for online materials.
If you start looking at
organizations out there,
I mean, which is the online
ed tech company which
has a $5 billion valuation?
Does anyone know?
So there's a company called 2U.
What is their model?
Their model is partnering
with universities like ours
to help us build the content,
and they would provide
the platform and the marketing.
This is a $5 billion enterprise.
It immediately starts raising
the question, hold on a second.
Wait, if we have the platforms,
if we can do the marketing--
I mean, you start seeing sort
of where this line of thinking
might go.
Again, short form content,
there's a lot of opportunities
there.
None of this is to say
that any improvements we
make in residential
should or will
end up with tuition increases.
I think that's a non-starter.
But, again, if we start thinking
about this as a portfolio,
at least I see a lot of
opportunity in terms of ways
to monetize that still allow us
to be very true to our mission.
So I'm, you know-- again, it's
nine days before I take over,
but I'm excited.
Could I just add something?
I appreciate your
question, but I
wouldn't want us to focus solely
on sustainability and revenue
issues.
There's a much broader
context that we should all
be thinking about,
and that is what
is the cost of
producing a Harvard
education in whatever part of
Harvard you're talking about.
And I think most
people believe that we
don't have a very sustainable
model in terms of our costs.
And here, I'm not talking
about our online endeavors.
I'm talking about our core
business of educating students,
students who are resident here.
And one of the promises
of online education
is that it will
improve productivity.
And this includes hybrid
versions, the kinds of things
that we're doing in various
parts of the university, where
there is an online component.
Many of you are
familiar with a study
that was carried out by Ithaca.
It was a randomized
trial to look
at what the effects of a
mostly online versus purely
residential curriculum
were in a set of colleges.
And it basically found that
outcomes were identical,
but it costs less to use
the online components.
I would wager if you
did the same thing here,
you might find outcomes
are better in hybrid
and costs are also
higher, especially
if you account for time costs.
And when you look
at most of what
we do in terms of pedagogical
innovation here at Harvard,
you're cost increasing.
Just think about it
across various schools.
Now, I don't want to name names,
but I'll go back in history
so I can name names.
I remember when I
was on the visiting
committee to the medical school,
there was another curriculum
reform back then,
and it involved
many more teachers per student.
And so I asked the person
who led the transformation,
I said, "Did you ever think
about a reform that might
actually lower your costs?"
And he looked at me like I
came from another planet.
No, I just came
from the West Coast.
But in any case, it was viewed
as kind of an odd question.
Several of the schools
here have engaged
in reforms that will
predictably increase costs.
VPAL office itself is
helping to move things
in the other direction.
And here, I want
to call out DART.
What you talked about, Bharat,
in terms of creating modules
in DART, which enables users
to find educational content
online, are both
ways that we can
avoid duplication of efforts.
And all of these resources
have been out there,
but they haven't
been accessible.
And this technology
makes it accessible.
And I also want to
call out Dustin's work
with syllabus finder.
I was actually just
putting together
a reading list for teaching
I'll be doing in the spring,
and I decided to
look up courses that
have anything to do with health
policy or the Affordable Care
Act.
Now, I found a lot
of courses, and I
have to admit I only found
one new reference that I
wanted to use.
But still, the fact that I
could do this with was huge.
We have we're at the cusp
of having technologies that
enable us to increase
productivity,
and the challenge that
we're going to face
is we want to increase
productivity in a way
that increases costs with the
hope of improving outcomes,
or in a way that enables
us to maybe reduce
the amount of expenditures
we have to make.
This is not an imminent
problem for us, in some ways,
but guaranteed over a
five to 10 year horizon,
we're going to have to think
about this very, very hard.
So we should stay
focused on that.
Incidentally, you may
know there are studies
that show that
for undergraduates
at elite universities, even
the full tuition rate that we
charge covers an
estimated maybe 50% to 60%
of the actual costs of
educating the students.
That's not a problem
that we're going
to solve purely by philanthropy
or whatever magic bullet people
may think we have.
But I just want
to point out VPAL
has been a leader in
thinking about how
to address these challenges.
We might as well end
it on that one, then.
So I just want to wrap
up the day very briefly.
And I want to actually
start with something
that Erin started
us off with, which
was an assumption that nobody
wants to be a bad teacher.
And, you know, I actually--
I do think that
that is a correct--
it's not just an assumption.
It's almost sort
of like a lemma.
It's so fundamental.
And here's a couple of
data points for that.
The first is that I think it is.
When people are struggling with
being an effective teacher,
part of it is there are lots
of different constraints.
Part of it is a
general understanding.
It's hard.
I mean, I've been teaching
now almost for 20 years.
Many of you have
been in the classroom
much longer than that.
None of us walks around thinking
that we've figured it out.
All of us are trying to explore.
And that's just motivated by not
wanting to sort of contradict
that assumption, right?
There is something
very joyful in being
able to instruct a
group of people that
really is like no other thing.
And it's also fun and engaging,
and you're with other people,
right?
I sit behind a computer
a lot, and that's
coding things and doing
sophisticated data analysis,
building technology tools.
That's really not that fun.
That's not that fulfilling.
And the human dimension
of teaching is, I think,
a reason--
that's why we're in this.
The other thing is, just to then
riff a little bit off of Erin,
part of this is about the
intentional university.
I think it's helpful
to remind ourselves
that the notion
of intentionality
is not exclusive
of other things.
I used to play a lot of
jazz, improvisational jazz,
some weird stuff
from the 70s, right?
I wasn't there, but it was
some pretty cool music.
And there was a set.
You know, you'd go in.
You'd choose a key.
And then, you just go with it.
And there's a rhythm,
and so on and so forth.
And I wasn't that--
my friends were a lot better.
And I was talking
to one of them.
I'm like, well, how
do you approach that?
He's like, well,
I'm very intentional
about my improvisation.
Well, what do you mean by that?
Well, I'm very intentional.
I listen to what
others are doing.
I interpret.
I try to feed new ideas
out to other musicians.
They're listening
to it, et cetera.
But all of that is a
very intentional process.
It's not like they're just
stepping in and saying, hey,
this is what I'm going to
do sort of off the cuff.
That is not how the production
of music was actually made.
And I think teaching has
a lot of those flavors.
It's good to innovate.
It's good to fail.
And, as Miles Davis
says, if you mess up,
do it again and call it jazz.
And I think that's kind of
what we're up to in this.
Finally, I'd just like to close
with how much it means to me
and I think Alan and Bharat
certainly, that all of you
keep coming back to
this convening event.
This year was a record
number of attendees.
Even at the lunch session,
we're at a record, as well.
And that to me shows not only
interest, but dedication.
The HILT community
is a great community,
and I can't wait to continue
to interface with all of you.
And with that, I'd like to
thank both Provost Garber
and incoming VPL Bharat
Anand for their time today.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]